donald trump has radically reshaped the
republican party
he has jettisoned many of the party's
long-held beliefs
and his unorthodox plain speaking
leadership style has curried favor with
a fiercely loyal supporter base join the
swan baby
he may have lost the election but trump
still managed to win
the second largest vote in american
presidential history
what's next for the republican party you
submitted your questions to idris
carloon u.s policy correspondent and
james
astol washington bureau chief
how much support for trump is actually
left in the party
trump is still by far the most popular
republican the most popular person in
his
party we have fresh polling on this
something
like half a bit more than half
republicans say
right now that trump should be the
party's candidate for the next general
election
in 2024 and above and beyond that
he has a sort of grip on his party
because
the most uh enthusiastic republicans
tend to be
the most devoted trump followers and
they can make trouble
for any dissident republican as we have
seen over the last four years
so trump effectively has still a very
strong
grip on his party and it's for that
reason that elected republican senators
congressmen and women have not called
foul on this
ludicrous uh legal challenge that the
president's been prosecuting to try to
overturn the results of the election
yeah i totally agree if you look at our
polling
you see that 80 plus percent of
republicans say that
uh donald trump uh had the election
stolen from him
and we see that some of his biggest
cheerleaders in in the senate right now
people like lindsey graham ted cruz and
marco rubio were his former opponents
who had very withering criticisms of him
but they've changed their tune and the
republican senators who
did not who defied the president have
largely been forced into early
retirement
i think that lock on party elites and
on the base are mutually reinforcing uh
but it doesn't seem like even after an
election loss that
uh that it's attenuated at all do you
think trumpism will still exist within
the republican party after trump leaves
office
trump has cast such an appall over his
party he's such a
gigantic maverick thoroughly
inconsistent
figure that trumpism really is the
leadership of donald trump albeit that
there are a few
consistent strains to trump's leadership
which i think would endure even if trump
was no longer the leader of the party
and i think they will endure so i think
that there will be no going back to sort
of
small government verities after
trump whenever that post-trump period
might be i think that the
republican party is liable to remain
populist
uh skeptical of uh free trade
uh highly um skeptical
of uh foreign engagements uh
multilateral organizations in other
words that
sort of populist isolationist tendency
that we've seen
rise and fall in american politics over
the decades
is likely to endure uh very strongly in
the republican party
even after trump goes those populist
strains will certainly endure in the
party
i think that it's hard to separate
trumpism from trump himself
if you look at some republican
candidates who you might point to as
having
tried to emulate that playbook it
doesn't seem to materialize in
in the turnout that the president has
been able to consistently
um engineer and so if trump recedes
uh from front view i think that maybe
there will be an opportunity for the
republican party to change its tune but
if he persists and i i don't think
there's any reason to doubt that he will
relish his role as a king maker for the
party in the coming years and perhaps
try to take up the mantle of the
presidency
um the presidential campaign in 2024
that the the grip that trumpism has over
the party will will continue
are we going to see more donald trump
type characters in the republican party
there are already a profusion of minor
caste characters there's the president's
own family his son donald trump jr
who very much has taken up the mantle of
his father and who is purportedly
looking into
uh running for some sort of higher
office you could see
something within the trump family itself
and then there have been intermittent
attempts at uh
replicating the populist trumpy playbook
within the republican party
uh i think with varying degrees of
success but
uh you know so far it seems tough to do
trumpism without trump himself
yeah i i quite agree with that trump you
know ludicrous
uh and a big loser as he may seem
is is a remarkable political force and
it's
it's it's tough to to replicate
his charisma um certainly as enjoyed by
his
devotees and also his his his
extraordinary conviction his
extraordinary shamelessness
in uh prosecuting his case for himself
he's a one-off i think but i think that
uh
a populist leader who has
taken note of the the temperature of his
party
and the issues that are popular within
his base
uh taking note from trump's success
that leader is likely to be successful
is the era of the republican party's
alternative facts
here to stay the mouthpieces on
the evening broadcast of fox news are
sort of currently
emblematic of an alternative fact
universe they have been cheerleaders
for trump and for his bending of of
reality
his alternative realities throughout the
past
four years however we're at the point
where we're contemplating
an even more loyal trumpist
uh right-wing media trump himself is
quite disaffected
disenchanted with fox news right now and
is urging his followers to
to watch some of these um even more
uh unashamedly pro-trump
uh networks and they have no qualms at
all newsmax
uh one american uh news network
these these uh uh new uh
even more ludicrously um loyal
trump uh uh mouthpieces uh
are are the the definition of an
alternative fact
universe so so in that sense i think
that we can see
not not only the alternative fact
industry still
continuing to chug away but you know
even more ludicrous monstrous
alternative reality taking shape on the
right how will the republican party
survive as the country becomes more
diverse
less white less religious and more
progressive
i think that their results this time
improving among african-americans and
hispanics suggested that they
can make some progress among minorities
that
as much as democrats may want the
demographic changes happening in this
country to be
a a destined permanent majority that's
not necessarily
the case hispanics and african-americans
to
to take the two uh demographic groups
that we think the president improved
upon
despite you know four years of what
college-educated liberals would look on
is
as racist uh actions of family
separation and whatnot
that despite that that he made gains i
think suggests that
you know it reflects the fact that among
these groups there's a high degree of
religiosity
um certainly much higher than the white
college educated liberals who are
increasingly
the base of the democratic party and
it's
it can't be taken for granted that uh
that folks uh of of those races will
will permanently vote for for the
democrats
we still don't know how much of that
bumper
support for democrats in the white
suburbs
was an anti-trump vote or was a sign of
a new
kind of um left-leaning allegiance
i think it's perfectly possible to
imagine that
a good uh portion of those suburbanites
would be very happy to
to drift back to a culturally
conservative
republican party that they have
for the longest time identified with if
it had a less offensive leader
will trump run again in 2024 and if so
who in the republican party might
challenge him
i think that if he runs as he reportedly
is contemplating
doing uh there will be very few folks in
the republican party
who would want to uh challenge the
president at this point i mean pity mike
pence who thought that it was his turn
this time
uh who will be entirely frozen out i
believe uh
you might see some opposition again from
the folks who opposed him in 2016
maybe ted cruz tries to challenge him
again he's clearly ambitious he has a
few more
presidential cycles left uh for him to
run in um the president probably
only has 2024 given his age um
but you know i think if he tried to do
it and if his health allowed him to
uh he at least at this point seems like
you have a
formidable chance of actually securing
the nomination again i think that things
could look quite different in
two years time and i think it's it's
possible to imagine
trump with uh rather less than uh
uh you know half of the party um
uh behind him still raging still
tweeting
still uh drawing thousands of people to
his
rallies but just not the same force in
the republican
party that he is currently it is
possible to imagine him
you know uh hubristically walking into a
a republican primary for 2024 and
finding that he's just not the man that
he
was i don't think that's beyond the
realms of imagination
and in that case i think you would get
quite a broad
spectrum of would-be successes standing
against him
if trump is strong almost goes without
saying that that sort of establishment
orthodox conservative
figure will uh get blown out the water
by trump and
actually i think even if trump is is
weak it's much
uh easier to imagine uh a populist
um of some shade um winning the party's
support
i i think ironically if trump were to
run in 2024
you know it might dissuade the trump
east members of the party from running
you know mike pence probably wouldn't be
able to run
uh christie noem the governor of south
dakota who has
raised their national profile by being
very close to the president um probably
in that case can't
can't run and in fact it might just
leave the um
folks who differ with the president as
the only one standing which which might
be an interesting turn but obviously
this is
uh four years is a very long time in
american politics to predict ahead
hi i'm idris kulun i'm the u.s policy
correspondent for the economist
you can read our latest coverage of the
republican party by clicking the link
here
thank you very much for watching and
please don't forget to subscribe